you think most men would be okay with
having a wife that does not have sex
with them no no okay no I think you've
got a problem okay yeah okay problematic
okay because you guys were like well
maybe if I explain to him why I'm not is
there a reason they could give you okay
you're like you know what I'm super
happy to just not have sex I think that
would be robbing salt into the wound to
be honest I think that might make it
worse if she's trying to justify it it's
like because the problem is what the
guy's giving you is his commitment he's
giving you his commitment I'm not going
to sleep with anyone else and then he's
and then if you're also not having sex
with him then obviously that's going to
leave him in a deficit